okay wonderful so happy that uh we could
be together today on uh you know as we
as we celebrate Thanksgiving and we're
we're well into the fall we get into the
holiday season and that's a time when uh
I guess a lot of people enjoy pumpkin
spice everything now I am uh
against pumpkin spice for a number of
reasons the first is that pumpkin spice
stuff doesn't taste like pumpkins at all
have you ever actually eaten like a
piece of a real pumpkin doesn't taste
anything like pumpkin spice stuff uh and
it just tastes bad and and the other
thing that I hate though also is
um beer is not beer I love beer but
um holiday themed or or any kind of like
creative flavor on a beer I don't like
any of that
and so my team here with of course they
they hate me and they like to watch me
suffer they had an idea for Content
which is which will be me trying
different versions of pumpkin spice beer
combining two things that I hate and
like let's let me suffer through it on
camera now I was told that just for a
little bit of background I was told that
well why don't you taste some of the
pumpkin spice beer and you know we'll
use it for content and I said okay and
then I walk in here and what they didn't
tell me is that we would also include
disgusting food as well which has
nothing to do with the pumpkin spice
theme there's no reason why this was not
explained to me why am I eating the food
to go along with it I don't understand
that and the worst thing is that the
food we have here these are all foods
that I like but it's the worst kind of
version of the foods that I like so it's
just an insult to me personally take
offense to it all right so let's go
through these uh our first one is
pumpkin Stout with pre-cooked bacon
oh my God that actually is really really
bad it's very it's very chemical it's
like a very it's I don't even taste the
pumpkin I don't taste pumpkin spice
there at all it's a very chemical like
almost it's like it's got a Drano it's
got a Drano flavor to it
um I don't know if they if I'm being
poisoned on camera for it's how
desperate they are for Content around
here that's going to kill me on camera
and then we got the uh pre-cooked bacon
which obviously is going to be
an insult no it's just what I thought
it's actually not that bad really I
gotta be honest with you but you know
that's actually better than I thought it
was gonna be
that's not too bad I mean it's it's not
it's not real bacon but
if you had to choose between
you don't have real bacon you gotta
choose between no bacon or this stuff
I'd go with that stuff that's actually
not so bad okay I'll give that a passing
grade next we have pumpkin spice latte
with frozen meatloaf has it been
unfrozen at least for me
oh dear God
that's not
what is that that's not even beer that's
just
tastes sour it tastes like um like a
candle I feel like I'm tasting like a
liquefied candle a scented candle I
don't understand what there's no way
anybody buys this stuff on purpose and
drinks it
all right now we've got the Frozen the
Frozen meatloaf okay why are we doing
this what's the point of this part of
this this is not even Thanksgiving
themed
oh they didn't even cook it thanks guys
[Music]
you know I actually I have like a
successful podcast now I don't need to
be doing this stuff why am I doing this
okay but we're not this desperate for
Content are we
I wouldn't even give that to my dog
I would not give that to my dog
I mean I would I hate my dog but
I wouldn't give that to a dog I liked
what the [ __ ]
I could never be I would starve rather
than eat that I would just die like I
like I've been broke in my life before
and but I've never been broke enough for
that and if I was I would just say well
then life is not for me I guess I'm just
dying I'll just die
there are worse things in life than
death
such as Frozen meatloaf you know sending
data over an unencrypted internet
connection is like sending a postcard
your message is wide open for the
mailman and any other nosy individual
you see whether you're connected to an
unencrypted internet Network on your
phone computer tablet or TV you're
sending countless pieces of information
out into the digital world that can be
seen and intercepted by pretty much
anyone a VPN creates a secure tunnel
between your device and the Internet
it's like putting your postcard in an
envelope so that no one can read your
letter before it gets to the person
you're trying to send it to expressvpn
is the VPN I trust to keep my data
secure expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that hackers can't steal
your personal data your passwords your
financial details Etc hackers make
serious cash selling personal
information on the dark web but
expressvpn makes it easier than ever to
keep your information safe just fire up
the old app click one button and you're
instantly protected plus expressvpn
works on all your devices so you can
stay secure on the go secure your online
data today at expressvpn.com Walsh YT
and get three extra months free that's
expressvpn.com Walsh YT expressvpn.com
Walsh YT okay this is pumpkin Stout with
canned chili literally in the can Nobody
Does this nobody was just like
Depression era times right now who's
eating
you can't even put it in a bowl for me
first is that even safe to eat it like
that
I mean that one's no that's bad okay for
a second I thought it was tolerable and
then I realized no it's so there's a
there's a brief moment with this when it
hits the front of your palette and
you're like that's not terrible but then
the despair is that it washes over your
palate the despair if there's a there's
so there's the aftertaste of Despair
that comes with it then we got this do I
really do you need to see me eating cold
canned chili out of a right out of the
can like I'm on a like I'm on a merchant
ship in the 1400s
okay yep that's terrible
just as I suspected
and I love chili like this is this is uh
this is blasphemy to me to make me eat
that
and they know that too that chili is my
it's my it's my one of my great loves in
life and I don't have very many
and then you just force me to endure
that that's bad finally pumpkin donut
Harpoon that don'ts is a pumpkin donut
beer with a jelly donut and I love
donuts but my least favorite kind of
donut is a jelly donut anytime there's a
box of donuts in the office whoever gets
them they always get at least two jelly
donuts and the two jelly donuts are
always sitting there last like someone
is forced to eat them because all the
better Donuts went before them but my
point is that just skip that why take up
real estate in the donut box with the
donut that's always last because nobody
wants it just substitute that for just a
regular glazed donut the glazed donuts
go first because everyone likes a glazed
no one dislikes a glazed donut
okay
pumpkin donut harpoon
[Music]
yeah it's like a
[Music]
it's like it tastes a little bit like a
pumpkin I never even had a pumpkin spice
latte but it tastes a little bit like a
pumpkin spice latte that's been sitting
for three weeks like in someone's Garage
in a old tin bucket and then you come in
and drink it that's what it tastes like
to me so I don't like it in other words
is what I'm trying to say all right then
I so you need to see me eating a jelly
donut just for
why do I have to do this
[Music]
oh whoops I just spilled on it by
accident well we can't do that
um
oh man that's uh we could reshoot this
entire thing but I don't think we want
to do that we don't have enough time for
that so
that's it I just I spilled on it by
accident it was an accident
that's it I'm not eating the jelly dog
you don't need to see me eat the jelly
donut okay I don't like them there's no
reason why I have to eat it it's not
like that's good
content to see Matt like everyone come
and watch Maddie the donut all right
fine damn it fine I'll just eat it I'll
eat it dipped in beer maybe that makes
it better
[Music]
no it doesn't make it better makes it
worse actually turns out so
don't spill beer on your donut it does
not improve the flavor at all but not
that you know it can't get any worse in
a
jelly donut
all right I'm getting it rationally
angry through this entire thing and so
that's it
have a uh Happy Thanksgiving everybody